Nick Josh congratulations you guys are
in the third and final round of this
competition now we're sending you back
for an easy time at your home Forge
recreating this iconic weapon from
history
today we are pre-testing the Chinese
jean-madau this is a Long Blade by far
the longest blade we've ever made this
sword by its sheer length was use
against Cavalry it's about that slash
and follow through like a circular
bandsaw but at a distance
measuring nearly six feet in length the
Zan McDow is a massive sword used by the
Song Dynasty of China primarily used
defensively against Cavalry attacks this
devastating weapon had the ability to
stop a charging horse with a single blow
the weapons long handle design allows
for better control and balance while
fighting against mounted enemies this
lethal sword is rumored to have been a
pivotal weapon for Chinese forces during
the Battle of yanchin when it was used
to defend against nearly 15 000 gin
Invaders on Horseback testing this is
quite interesting on how this sword has
to be wielded to be effective to use it
you really have to think about the
function of a Long Blade a long handle
and how you're going to move with
something this long it's not a pocket
knife the balance is different it's a
longer weapon at the same time to be
effective with slashing something this
long you have to use a lot of your legs
your hips as well as your arms
we pre-tested this weapon on a war
the closest thing we can get to Cavalry
right that way we can tell with the
slashing motion of this weapon can do
drag it
the first shot alone you got to make
sure you're very effective one
two
three the recovering is something this
long it may take some time to get to
another shot
these pre-tests actually allow me a
chance to gauge my distancing from the
Target and from everything around me and
training myself on how to use this
weapon to get the desired results for
the test that we're going to be doing
good luck blade Smiths we'll see you in
four days
good luck brother
foreign
my name is Nick Meyer I'm from Elizabeth
Colorado I retired from the Army in 2012
the transition was challenging and so
blacksmithing and knife making was part
of that transitional growth I really
want to get the entire blade shaped out
the blade is rough shaped now I can get
busy grinding and hopefully by the end
of the day to get it quenched
this is going to be a day filled with
attention to detail this is the most
nerve-wracking part it's kind of the
make or break moment
so pull it out of the forge get it in
the oil perfect I pull it out
I didn't get a curve on it
I need it to have a curve on it because
that will allow it to function the way
it needs to
I've got to stick it back in the fire
and I've got to get it quenched this is
not what I wanted to have happen so here
we go again quench number two
it didn't break best off there's a
little bit of a curve in it so I'm going
to start working on my guard
after a lot of file work I get the guard
fit right up to the shoulders it looks
perfect
[Music]
my name is Joshua Weiser I've been
bladesmithing for about two years
I'm coming on to forger fire because I
want to prove to my kids that they have
something they're really passionate
about they go after it this is what I'm
starting with big old piece 5160 my
forage only has about 18 inches it'll
just be working on it a little bit at a
time
we got the length
we're doing about everything I can to
try and get it as even as possible but
here we go
[Music]
coming out of the quench is going to be
a real challenge so I clamp it down in
some 2x4s the idea here is to help try
and keep it as straight as I can while
it cools got the bevel ground in and I'm
gonna start working on getting this
handle fit up
I'm gonna glue these two pieces together
do some sculpting I'm actually going to
make a little bit smaller than I would
because I plan on doing a wrap
have a little bit of time left so start
working on shaping the guard
doing a little fit on the guard
I'm happy with the shape overall
yeah that'll work
bladesmiths welcome to the Keel test
well your zamadows aren't pocket knives
they definitely look very long but what
kind of lethal damage can they do to
find that out I will take your weapons
deliver some slashes and killing blows
on this boar carcass
I think you're pretty ready for this yes
sir
[Music]
all right thanks talk about your weapon
here
now the design you have I was expecting
a little bit more of a curve because of
a straighter blade it feels more like
I'm chopping before I'm drawing but as
you can see
you look cute thank you
all right Josh your returns are you
ready let's do it
[Music]
all right Josh let's talk about your
blade here the balance is good in as
much as I can feel the power in there I
can wield this weapon and develop some
speed and power and the curvature that
you have here does exactly what this
kind of design is meant to do every cut
was very deep on this carcass enough to
where it cut all the way through and
more importantly
you'll kill thank you all right
gentlemen welcome to the strength test
now to test the strength and overall
construction rear blades I'll be
chopping into the pots and this horse
skull now remember gentlemen this is not
about what your blades do to the targets
this is about what those targets are
going to do to your blades
Nick you're up are you ready yes sir
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
there's not really any chipping or
rolling that I can feel it's just sort
of just lost its its fine Edge yes sir
most of these weapons have a bit more of
a curve and and this it's got about as
slight a curve as I could call a curve
yes sir it's a very very flexible blade
but it did well so nice and done thank
you sir
all right Josh
let's do it
so Josh very well crafted blade which I
like the guard the dimensions the size
and the shape of the handle all really
beautiful
fortunately though we've got some
rolling on the edge of this blade you
hear that
yeah so you put an incredibly fine Edge
on this and it showed in the kill test
but uh
not so good for hitting pots
it's a great feeling weapon but uh yeah
it did take that edge damage all right
please fits now it's time to find out
how sharp your blades are this is the
sharpness desk the Dual Sandman slice
now unlike the strength test this is all
about what the edge of your blade does
to the Sandman
make your purse ready for this yes sir
sweet
[Music]
all right next talk about your blade
here as you can see it cut the arms cut
the legs this embold the rice off the
Torso overall sir it won't cut thank you
sir
all right Josh your turn so you ready
let's do it
[Music]
yeah dude
all right Josh
this is a cutter just a design of it
really lends itself to really draw cut
the cuts are very deep and they're very
clean when you're cutting through the
rolling it took did not affect its
cutting ability so overall sir
okay we'll cut thank you
blade Smiths the judge's deliberation is
complete they've made their final
decision the new forged and fire
Champion is
Josh congratulations
Nick your blade didn't make the cut Doug
Marquette is going to tell you why
Nick the zamandal was designed to be a
horse Slayer or Chopper the amount of
flex you have on your blade and the lack
of curvature made it perform less than
that of your competitor
all right Nick at this time please leave
the forge come on forward my friend
I may not be the forged and fire
Champion but by no means do I consider
myself a loser when it came down to the
decision today just wasn't my day
foreign
fire champion and that's the title that
comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars I want for him I'm a portrait
pirate champion and I don't even know
what to think right now it's something
that I can show my kids that if you put
your mind to something 100 you can
really accomplish something